Viking sont bloqués sur le pont du
bateau depuis 11 jours depuis 11 jours
ils attendent de pouvoir débarquer dans
un port sûr ah c'est bien ça ajoute 79
personnes sous couru à bord de
l'humanités
soit un total de 952 personnes rescapées
j'aimerais dire à la collègue durant ce
moment national qui du haut du perso de
la Semaine Nationale crois pouvoir
organiser les opérations de sauvetage en
Méditerranée avec la plus grande
désinvolture et sans d'autres mérites
dans sa vie que d'être né dans un pays
en paix je vous le dis ne vous en
déplaise leur vie compte
l'océan de Viking a adressé aujourd'hui
sa septième demande d'assistance aux
autorités maritimes italienne mal tout
aussi proche un tout simplement pas
répondu aux droits de monde qui ont été
adressés ce blocage de personnes est une
jeunesse sont grave du droit de la mer
et évaluation du statut de nationalité
des personnes secourues ne doit pas
retarder du Mans le débarquement des
survivants
je ne veux pas que partager l'inquiétude
de ces migrants à l'heure la nouvelle
Première ministre italienne s'est engagé
à bloquer leur arrivée des migrants en
provenance d'Afrique quelle sera donc
l'action du Gouvernement sur ce sujet
quelle forme prendra la coopération avec
Italie allez vous vous saisir de la
question de la répartition des migrants
avec d'autres pays européens comme Malte
qui ne répond plus aux demandes de
coordination de sauvetage les personnes
secourues se trouvent dans une situation
d'urgence absolue des prévisions météo
indiquent une détérioration
significative du climat
pas du tout
c'est
[Applaudissements]
quel
est le député qui vient de prononcer
cette phrase
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suspension de séance de 5 minutes